up into the hills of much of the
occupied West Bank there are illegal
settlements block after block these are
home to more than 600,000 Israeli
settlers on Palestinian land while
international law stipulates they're
illegal the UN has got a step further
and listed companies with ties to
settlements in the end from an initial
321 companies whose names are submitted
to us and whose activities were reviewed
the report identifies 112 companies it's
important to note that it is not as some
claim a blacklist nor does it qualify
any company's activities is illegal that
would be a separate and highly
complicated determination and is
something which ultimately could only be
decided on a case-by-case basis through
a competent judicial process this list
includes well-known international
companies such as Airbnb although the
report doesn't state that the company's
activities are illegal Israeli
politicians say they may now be targeted
by the activist group boycott divestment
and sanctions Palestinians say this list
will prove useful we need to work with
with the office of High Commissioner the
High Commissioner because she has to to
update this list annually we need to
work with the states with countries
toward build their responsibilities and
to hold and assume their
responsibilities to talk to these
companies telling them that what they
are doing is illegal in a statement
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu said the UN Human Rights
Council is a biased and influential body
instead of dealing with human rights
this body is trying to blacken Israel's
name we reject any such attempt in the
strongest terms and we've discussed the
proposed US peace plan released last
month through Palestinian condemnation
for agreeing to let Israel maintain
control of the settlements most
countries and the UN view illegal
Israeli settlements as one of the most
contentious issues in the conflict
Israel now says it's considering
annexing settlements Palestinians say
they won't ever allow that
happen nor about manly al Jazeera